well guys congratulations your hard work
paid off and the two of you are moving
forward in the third and final round now
blake's missing the first two rounds
this competition you got to choose your
challenges but we are taking back
control and we want you to to build this
the tibetan sword
the tibetan sword also called the
dapadam traces its origins back to the
calm region of eastern tibet during the
18th century
this straight single-edged blade
features an oblique tip perfect for
delivering fast fatal slashes and deep
deadly thrust on an enemy combatant
while warriors carry this fierce sidearm
into battle it was most commonly worn by
tibetan chieftains in royalty while the
tibetan sword is no longer used in
combat this weapon can still be seen
today at the metropolitan museum of art
in new york city
well guys you will only have four days
of your home forges to build your
dependent swords one of them is going to
be worth the title a fortune fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars so good luck gentlemen we will
see you in four days all right
good luck man all right
my name is josh ferrand i'm 33 and i
work in aerospace engineering
i'm also a farmer i do leather work i
drive race cars and yeah i'm heck and
tired
so i've got this scene drawn out it's
time to cut it and reset
i've got these weld set but the more
difficult part is going to be cutting
the feather into this billet
as i'm forcing the feather tool through
the billet
oh that's not good i worked it too long
the edges broke loose if these welds
come apart i don't know what i'm gonna
do
the billet's useless it's time for plan
b oh my gosh i take a piece of adcrv2 to
make a mono steel blade got my mono
steel blade fortune shape
there it is now it's time for the handle
i've never done a wire wrap before so
i'm just gonna figure it out as i go
i thought i was gonna be that guy
turning in an incomplete blade
but with seconds to spare i finish it
there it is
i'm cliff ivey i'm from fort smith
arkansas if you get into bladesmithing
it is work you will figure that out real
quick but my reward for this is the
gratification i have met the best people
that i never would have met any other
way
i'm moving and grooving i've actually
luckily have gotten to the point where i
can quench
i feel great quenched on day one yeah
baby i want a weapon that's light so
what i'm gonna do is go with a wood
pummel instead of a metal one to keep
the weight down
it's simple it's effective it's going to
work great
looks good
i want a blue back at one time
and then i'll be sharpening
win or lose i'm ready to see it in
action bladesmiths welcome to the keel
test
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your tibetan swords can do
joshua first you ready for this may as
well all right let's do this
i am nervous
all right josh in swinging your blade
the edge you have
is
sharp
each chop and slice in there is very
deep overall sir your weapon
your keel thank you doug
all right cliff here turns are you ready
oh yes let's do it let's do this
pigs are no joke it'll absorb a blade
and snap that sucker off
[Music]
all right cliff
your pommel looks great but if it was
metal it would help with the bounce to
bring it back a little bit rather to be
very forward heavy
the edge you have here is very sharp and
with the weight pushing it it cut the
pig all the way through overall sir your
tibetan sword it'll kill
all right gentlemen welcome to ceramics
with dave
our strength test
remember it's not about what your blades
do to these pots but what these pots do
your blades and josh you are up first
break the pots not the blade
i'll do my best
[Music]
oh wow all right josh
it's a very nicely balanced weapon but
that extremely acute edge you have there
has taken some damage still completely a
viable blade good job
all right cliff you're up are you ready
smash and bash
[Music]
all right cliff
without the counterbalance
it's very forward heavy it makes it a
slower blade to fight with and control
now getting up on your blade here very
similar damage in that there are a lot
of very small nicks and chips out of
your edge
but
uh it's still in one piece so well done
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the rug slice
josh your first ready for this
as well let's do it
all right josh as you can see in this
section that took some damage it cuts
but you can feel it get hung up on the
rug
but overall sir it will cut
thanks doug
all right cliff your turns are ready yes
sir let's do this
[Music]
all right cliff in the areas that took
damage on the strength test you can see
that they ripped some pieces of the rug
the forward weight of this you can see
it easy lends to coming down look when
you're cutting up it's harder to wield
but overall sir it will cut
thank you
all right josh cliff we wanted to bring
tibetan swords that were sharp that were
strong and wieldable and both of you did
exactly what we asked but in this
competition there can only be one
fortune fire champion
today's fortune fire champion is
josh congratulations
now cliff unfortunately your tibetan
sword didn't make the cut today your
time in the flip the script competition
has ended i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor
thank you for having me
thank you for coming cliff thank you am
i a little disappointed yes but i've
been challenged in a really really good
way
so i have a lot to be thankful for
well josh you are the newest fortune
fire champion you got yourself a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you guys
how do you feel
fantastic i never thought i would be at
this moment it's truly a blessing to be
where i am right now it was hard fought
and i'm incredibly grateful to be here
this has been an unreal experience
you